early morning in go Lorraine forest
national park a team of Rangers and
researchers are looking for the tracks
of one of the world's rarest animals the
pygmy hippo I want to see the pygmy
hippo laughs really
it is difficult for me since I started
working out who sets the eyes on pygmy
people so honestly I want to see the
pygmy hippo physically that's really
made for most species for now this
camera trap is helping them it's
estimated there are only 2,000 pygmy
hippos left there only one-quarter the
size of normal hippos and live almost
exclusively here in the upper Guinean
forests ghola park is one of the few
remaining primary forests in Sierra
Leone the park contains many endangered
animal and plant species most of a why
and his team patrol the area day and
night Sierra Leone is among the poorest
countries in the world so it's not
surprising that local residents have
sometimes tried to exploit some of the
parks resources
the main challenge estates wanting and
mining elegant many but and we have we
have on top of situation we have be able
to control that one for now
everything is under control really most
of her knows the park can only be
protected if the people who live nearby
can survive without having to hunt or
fish in it staff members have formed
strong bonds with the neighboring
communities to find new sources of
income for them one solution Trading
cocoa beans muster for wise colleague
Aminata Barrera is creating a network of
cocoa farmers to export their products
Muhammad Koroma cultivates cocoa but so
far he hasn't made much of a profit
which of the cocoa beans a good enough
quality for export
I mean artis shows them harvesting cocoa
is not only good for farmers the forest
profits as well cocoa itself it's a
forest free from of the board
they also come and feed there so it's
really good for this conservation
activities cocoa trees only grow well in
the shadow of larger trees so here on
the edge of the National Park the forest
is being preserved that stops the ground
from drying out and offers a habitat for
birds insects and monkeys this is the
collection point more than a thousand
farmers are part of the project it's
easier to sell the cocoa in bulk
quality control the pods have to be
carefully fermented and dried I mean not
as happy on Mohammed gets over 40 US
dollars for 25 kilos a minute and her
colleagues are now looking for an
international buyer for their organic
fair trade cocoa I feel great good very
much happy if our dreams come true for
us to be able to sell it in overseas and
at the end of the day for also have a
gulab brand chocolates the Kola
chocolates Ranger must have a why and
his team are pitching their camp in the
park tomorrow they'll go on another
patrol I haven't seen any pygmy hippos
today
no poachers either it was a quiet day
75% of the Rangers are coming from these
communities and if the program can
continue for another 20 years then there
is more development in our communities
so I'm really proud about it in most
areas of Sierra Leone species are
disappearing
but in go Lorraine Forest National Park
biodiversity is being preserved
you